[موسيقى]
مساء الخير انقلاب جديد في افريقيا الثامن
على التوالي في 3 سنوات هذه المره في دوله
الغابون امس الاربعاء الموافق 30 اغسطس
استيقظ اهالي الجابون على اعلان المتوقع
فوز الرئيس علي بنجو بولايه ثالثه مدتها
سبعه سنوات لكن غير المتوقع هو ما حدث بعد
الاعلان بنحو ساعه مجموعه من الضباط قطعوا
بث التليفزيون ليعلنوا البيان رقم واحد
للانقلاب على الرئيس قالوا في هذا البيان
باسم الشعب الجابوني قررنا الدفاع عن
السلام ووضع نهايه للنظام القائم ندعو
المواطنين للهدوء والسكينه برروا تحركهم
بما وصفوه بالسلوك غير المسؤول للرئيس
الذي زور الانتخابات وهدد استقرار البلد
وتماسكه واعلنوا الغاء الانتخابات طبعا
نتائج الانتخابات وحل كل المؤسسات الدوله
وتاسيس مجلس انتقالي لحكم الجابون حتى
موعد اقامه انتخابات اخرى جديده حره نزيهه
واعدين الشعب بحياه افضل معبرين عن هذا
بعباره فريده في بيانا انقلاب يا شعب
الجابون نحن اخيرا على طريق السعاده
الانقلاب جاء صادما للكثير من القوى
الخارجيه وخصوصا فرنسا التي اعتبرت
الانقلاب ضربه جديده
للنفوذ الفرنسي في افريقيا النظم المواليه
لفرنسا والغرب بتسقط الواحد تلو الاخر
ويحل محلها نظم ساخطه على على فرنسا من
المبكر جدا الاجابه على اسئله كثيره اولها
الدوافع الحقيقيه للانقلاب توجهات الضباط
الذين يحكمون
الجابون الان فرص نجاح الانقلاب اصلا رد
فعل القوى الخارجيه سواء داخل القاره او
من جانب القوى الكبرى امريكا الصين روسيا
والاهم طبعا فرنسا
ثم تاثير الانقلاب على اقتصاد العالم
الماذون الجابون منتج للبترول والغاز
والمنجنيز والاورانيوم والاخشاب كل هذه
الاسئله لا احد يملك عليها اجابات قاطعه
الاجابات سوف تكون اوضح في الايام القليله
المقبله لكن اليكم ما نعرفه حتى الساعه
المحرك الاساسي لهذا الانقلاب هو الرغبه
في التخلص من حكم اسره بونجو وليس فقط
الرئيس علي بونجو وهذا يجعل انقلاب
الجابون مختلفا على الانقلابات الاخيره
التي حدثت في دول الساحل واخرها النيجر
الانقلابات هناك كان سببها الرئيسي المعلن
هو ضجر الضباط من انفلات الامن وعجز
الحكومات القائمه عن التصدي للجماعات
المتطرفه لكن وطبعا في حلقه عن انقلاب
النيجر استاذنكم ان يعني ان تشاهدوها حتى
لا نكرر ما جاء فيها وده بياخذنا الى
الجوهري من هي اسره بونجو التي تم
الانقلاب عليها وتسعى كثير من القوى
الخارجيه لاعادتها لي السلطه الاجابه
تتطلب معرفه الف باء جابون اي اطلاله
سريعه على تاريخ وجغرافيا هذا البلد
جغرافيا الجابون كما توضح الخريطه بتقع في
غرب افريقيا على مساحه اجماليه تقدر
بحوالي 268 الف كيلو مترا مربعا ده اكثر
من ثلاث امثال دوله مثل الامارات المساحه
دي بتصبح كبيره جدا اذا عرفنا ان عدد سكان
الجابون اقل من اتنين واربعه من عشره
مليون نسمه فقط اتنين مليون و400 الف
مواطن اقل من نصف عدد سكان مدينه
الاسكندريه في مصر على سبيل المثال البلد
بيتمتع باطلاله طويله مئات الكيلومترات
على خليل غينيا وخليه غينيا هو جزء من
المحيط الاطلنطي
88% من مساحه الجابون غابات واشجار وهذه
ظاهره فريده في اي بلد في العالم
ولذلك نسبه التلوث الاجماليه فيها صفر
والحياه البريه احد اهم مصادر الجذب
السياحي اقتصاديا بيتمتع الجابون بموارد
اقتصاديه مغريه ثروه من البترول والغاز
والبعادن ومنها اليورانيوم والمنجنيز
بالاضافه للاخشاب ولهذا بتنشط عشرات
الشركات الكبرى خصوصا الشركات الفرنسيه
والصينيه هناك اجمال الناتج المحلي
للجابون حوالي 21 مليار دولار وهذا يجعل
متوسط نصيب الفرد من الناتج المحلي مرتفعا
بالنسبه لكل دول افريقيا متوسط نصيب الفرد
في الجابون بيبلغ حوالي
8800 دولار في السنه وفقا لارقام 2022
طبيعه الحال بيجعل متوسط نصيب الفرد
الجابوني اكثر من ضعفي متوسط نصيب الفرد
المصري ونصيب الفرد الجزائري اللي بيبلغ
حوالي 4000
دولار في السنه واكثر بكثير من متوسط نصيب
المواطن الليبي البالغ حوالي 6700 دولار
واكثر من ثلاثه امثال نصيب المواطن الهندي
في السنه البالغ حوالي
2400 دولار متوسط نصيب الفرد ببساطه بيتم
من خلال قسمه الناتج المحلي الاجمالي على
عدد السكان 21 مليار دولار ليس كثيرا
بالنسبه لكل الدول اللي انا ذكرتها ولكن
لان عدد السكان صغير جدا فنصيب الفرد من
ال 21 مليار دولار كبير ومرتفع بالنسبه
لكل دول افريقيا لكن هذا طبعا على الورق
فقط هذه الارقام لا تعكس الواقع بدقه
الثروه في الجابون مثل كثير من دول العالم
بتتركز في ايدي نسبه بسيطه بتحتكر الثروه
والسلطه وطبعا النسبه الصغيره ديت بتتركز
في عائله بونجو واصدقائها وفقا لتقديرات
البنك الدولي ثلث الشعب الجابوني فقير
واربعين في المئه من الشباب عاطل عن العمل
تاريخيا كان اول زوار الجابون من
الاوروبيين التجار البرتغاليون الذين
وصلوا هناك في القرن ال 15 سرعان ما اقتدب
ساحل الجابون وغاباته الساحره مغامرين
وتجار من كل القوى الاوروبيه واصبح ساحل
الغابون على الاطلنطي مركزا لتجاره العبيد
والرقيق قطعت فرنسا الطريق على اطماع
الاوروبيين في الجابون واحتلتها 1885 ثم
اصبحت الجابون بدايه من 1910 واحده من
الاقاليم الاربعه في كيان فيدرالي اساسته
فرنسا تحت اسم افريقيا الاستوائيه
الفرنسيه هذه الفيدراليه ضمت الى جانب
الجابون افريقيا الوسطى وتشهاد والكونغو
مع جلاء فرنسا عن مستعمراتها تفكك هذا
الاتحاد واصبحت اقاليمه الاربعه دول
مستقله بدايه من عام 1960 في 63 سنه
الماضيه اي منذ استقلال الجابون لم يعرف
اهالي الجابون الا ثلاثه رؤساء فقط الرئيس
الاول هو ليون انبا الذي مات فيه مارس
1967 ثم رئيسها الثاني والتاريخ البرت
بونجو الذي اصبح لاحقا عمر بانجو بعد ان
اعتنق الاسلام في سنه 1973
وقصه اسلامه عليها كثير من علامات
الاستفهام والاسئله وفقا لبعض المهتمين
بتاريخ عائله بونبو ودوله الجابون بصفه
عامه يعتقدون ان اسلامه كان لاسباب سياسيه
ورغبته في ان يقوي علاقته بدول الاوبك
اللي معظمها مسلمين وعرب ولكن هذه قصه
يطول شرحها على كل الاحوال اعتنق الاسلام
غير اسمه وكذلك تغير اسم ابنه عليه
الصحف الفرنسيه هي اكثر من كتب عن فساد
عائله بونجو وعلاقاتها المريبه بالنخب
الفرنسيه باختصار لان ده موضوع كتب عنه
كثيرا الاب ثم الابن متهماني بمراكمه ثروه
ضخمه هم من اغنى اغنياء العالم ولكن مصدر
ثروتهم طبعا غير مشروعه جاءت من خلال
السطو على اموال الجابونيين وبهذه الثروه
اشتروا ولاء النخب الفرنسيه
وتحقيقات صحفيه كثيره كتبت عن دبلوماسيه
حقائب الاموال التي كان يفضلها عمر بنجو
لشراء دعم النخب الفرنسيه وكلام كثير كتب
ايضا عن مساهمه عائله بونجو في تمويل
الحملات الرئاسيه لرؤساء مثل جاك شيراك
وساركوزين وفي مقابله اجريت سنه 2001 مع
صحيفه ليبرسيون الفرنسيه اعترف مايك
جوكتان السياسي الجابوني بان رشوه
السياسيين الفرنسيين كانت مكشوفا في
الجابون كان الجميع يعلم انه حين ياتي
زعيم او سياسي فرنسي الى الجابون فانه
يغادر في اغلب الاحوال بحقيبه مملوءه
بالاموال وعائله بونجو كانت كريمه مع
الفرنسيين فهي تقدم الرشاوي للجميع بغض
النظر عن انتماءاتهم السياسيه وذلك للنفاذ
الى كل دوائر صنع القرار في فرنسا ولماذا
فرنسا لانها كانت وما زالت صاحبه النفوذ
الاكبر على الجابون حتى بعدما تعهد علي
بونجو في 2010 بان لا يكون نفوذ فرنسا على
بلاده حصري وفتح الابواب بالفعل امام
استثمارات دول اخرى على راسها الصين لكن
ظلت فرنسا تتمتع بنفوذ هائل فاللغه
الرسميه هي الفرنسيه شركات فرنسيه ناشطه
في كل القطاعات الاقتصاديه الحيويه قاعده
عسكريه دائمه
لفرنسا تضم حوالي 4 00 جندي هناك باريس هي
قبله الحكومه وقبله المعارضه ويقرئ اهالي
الجابون بانه لا يمكن ابدا ان ياتي رئيس
لبلادهم دون موافقه فرنسيه على الاقل حتى
قيام انقلاب 30 اغسطس الماضي
وبعيدا عن العلاقات المشبوهه مع فرنسا
والرشاوي السياسيه ادانه المحاكم الفرنسيه
ابناء الرئيس عمر بونجو اي اخوه واخوات
الرئيس المخلوع علي بونجو في قضايا فساد
واستيلاء على اموال الشعب الجابوني
اما تزوير الانتخابات فهو امر مشهود به من
الجميع تقريبا
ومنذ ساعات قليله المسؤولين في الاتحاد
الاوروبي اذان طبعا الانقلاب وقالوا ان
الانقلاب امر غير مقبول ولكن في نفس الوقت
الانقلاب تم بعد انتخابات شابهه الكثير من
التزوير وكانهم يلتمسون العذر لضباط الجيش
الذين انقلبوا على
علي بنجو التزوير مش مرتبط بس بانتخابات
2023 التي اجريت في 26 اغسطس الماضي
واعلنت نتائجها يوم 30 اغسطس حين تم
الانقلاب لا ابدا ده هي قصه طويله على
مدار سنوات طويله مسلسل طويل من التزوير
في الانتخابات واغتصاب السلطه عن طريق هذا
التزوير والتزوير بيتم او تم في احوال
كثيره بطريقه فكه يعني في انتخابات 2016
على سبيل المثال فاز علي بونجو باكثر من
96 في المئه من الاصوات في مسقط راسه اللي
هي مقاطعه اجوي على ما اذكر اذا كنت منطقه
صح
ده لا يبدو غريبا لكن الغريب نسبه الاقبال
السته وتسعين في المئه ديت كانت من نسبه
اقبال بلغت
99.98 في المئه الصحف الفرنسيه وقتها كتبت
بما انه عدد
الاشخاص المسجلين في هذه المقاطعه هم 71
الف شخص يعني يحق له الانتخاب ده معناه ان
12 شخص فقط في هذه المقاطعه لم ياتي
للادلاء بصوته امر شبه مستحيل خصوصا ان
علي بونجو رجل لا يتمتع بشعبيه تذكر في
الجابون هو في اذهان الكثير من معارضيهم
مجرد واجهه لعائله بنجو او ابن الرئيس
يطلق عليه اهالي الجابون في اشاره الى ان
كل مؤهلات والتي جاءت به الى السلطه هو
انه ابن عمر بنجو لاكثر ولا اقل
ولانه ابن الرئيس فهو اصبح وزيرا للخارجيه
وهو عنده 30 سنه ثم وزير للدفاع سنه 99 ثم
رئيسا في 2009
طاردت علي بنكو شائعات تنتقص من شعبيه اي
سياسي واحده من هذه الشائعات انه اجنبي
وليس جابونيا والشائعه دي بتقول ان هو طفل
تبناه عمر بنجو اثناء الحرب الاهليه في
نيجيريا وجاء به ورباه ثم اصبح رئيسا على
اهالي الجابون
معارضوه بيهاجموه لاسباب كثيره منها
عاداته المكلفه واسرافه واضح يعني وبلعوا
بالسيارات الفارهه وعدم معرفته باللغات
المحليه للكابون ثم او اضف الى كل ذلك صحه
الرئيس متداعيه بخصوصا بدايه من 2018 لما
اصيب بسكته دماغيه ابعدته عن المشهد
الاكثر من عشر شهور وتداعي صحته
او عزز الانطباع لدى كثير من الشعب
الجابوني ان من يدير شؤون البلاد هي اسره
بونجو وليس الرئيس نفسه اذا نجح الانقلاب
وانتهى حكم اسره بونجو فسوف يكون ذلك على
الارجح ضربه جديده لنفوس فرنسا
فالجابون كان قلب منطقه النفوذ الفرنسي
فالجابون كان واحده من قلاع النفوذ في
فرنسا وعمر بنجو هو الذي قال ذات مره
افريقيا بدون فرنسا مثل سياره بدون سائق
وفرنسا بدون افريقيا مثل سياره بدون بنزين
ولكن هذه قصه اخرى نتناولها في حلقات
مقبله باذن الله اشكركم والى اللقاء